thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even
how are you guys doing I recently came
across a video of Neil deGrasse Tyson an
individual who I've been hammering
lately yes hammering
and who deserves the hammering let's
watch the video and come back and
respond in kind I care what is
objectively true in the world as a
scientist
but let me not say even as a scientist I
just simply care what is objectively
true and science happens to be a pretty
potent
path
to invoke to find out what is true
and so
if people Express themselves on a gender
spectrum and that is an actual thing in
an actual Society
if we have not fully explained that
scientifically that's an interesting
Frontier to study
if you want to say it's only
sociological
then it's the purview of the social
sciences
I don't care who studies it it's an
interesting fact about Society that's
worth learning about
if to make it to fight someone and say
it's not biological it's just your this
is
it's real and it's there well because
it's real because it manifests what I
find most egregious about this video is
that this is an individual who has been
a mascot for the new atheists yes a
mascot
for the new atheists an individual
who was blasting religion on the basis
that doesn't have empirical evidence for
his validity and here he is talking
about objective reality in one breath
and in the other breath he's talking
about what
the fact that you have an expression
he's talking of course about the
expression of somebody of another gender
and so on like the fact that you have
this expression in his words is a
manifestation of was a real
manifestation reality it was it's real
because it manifests in reality couldn't
the same exact line of reasoning be
afforded to every single religion on the
face of the Earth
every single fiction every single myth
on the face of the Earth
it's real
it has ontological significance
conceptual significance actual realistic
real significance because it manifests
itself
in the world
that is not the standard that you use
Neil when you deal with religion
but here you are the traitor that you
are to your own profession
the traitor that you are to your own
profession as a scientist cannot even
summon the courage
the fortitude
The Bravery
to say actually
this is something which is unscientific
this is something which is against basic
biology the fact that somebody expresses
themselves in x-way the social construct
this social fiction
referred to as
gender
transitioning or considering yourself
something to be another this is a
fiction actually it's a figment of one's
imagination it's a kind of delusion
wait a minute what do you mean is a kind
of delusion the same kind of delusion
that if you remember Richard Dawkins
because he thought the only way to
finding out things was through
empiricism and you agreed with him
the materialist and naturalist the
physicalist that you are
but you don't employ
your empiricism your naturalism your
physicalism or your materialism when
you're dealing with a gender issue you
sideline it you're worried to speak and
say certain things that will offend
certain people
you coward
you are a coward you are a coward
I watched the entire video and saw how
much you tried to evade answering Ben
Shapiro's question
Ben Shapiro's question
who on these issues we agree with
about how these things are not
biological realities and you are trying
to escape that conflating and
equivocating and creating red herrings
and distractions from that question
and instead try to equivocate
and the manifestation of the expression
of an individual to uh another gender is
the same is real because what do you
mean it's real why are you using the
word real
because what the question initially was
was is this individual actually X Y and
Z from a biological perspective
you have no defense you have no defense
and I don't want to hear anything from
you
yeah
I don't want to hear that because even
Richard Dawkins even he was courageous
enough to speak about these issues and
to call a spade a spade
but until you come out and admit the
gender delusion
it's not The God Delusion suggest
resolution which is causing irreversible
damage to people which is causing
which is subjecting children
to confusion mental psychological
confusion even now talk of pumping them
with steroids and
you know hormones
miseducating them
teaching them your Western fiction
Western fiction
Western mythology
religion of the left
yes
until you come out and speak about that
religion
then you're not a man at all
you're coward
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah Allah will build for
him a Sim at the house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale